foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter theory in today's video we're
going to be discussing the cast members
of Harry Potter specifically we're going
to be addressing what the iconic Harry
Potter cast full of superstars is doing
now when we think of the Harry Potter
films it's hard to believe that the most
recent installment came out over a
decade ago with the Deathly Hallows Part
2 hitting the Silver Screen in 2011 but
if that doesn't sound like a long time
ago then it may surprise you to hear
that the first installment the
Philosopher's Stone came out a decade
before that in 2001 but while it's been
quite some time since we've seen the
original cast in action they did give us
10 years of great movies which I'll be
forever grateful for unfortunately for
those who've been patient however you
will be pleased to hear that it was just
announced a few days ago on HBO's
official Twitter page that Warner Bros
will be focusing on a new h Biomax Harry
Potter TV series from the sounds of
things we'll be getting a new Harry
Potter cast but that's not confirmed and
there's always the possibility for a
familiar face to pop up in the right
context which is why I wanted to explore
what 50 main Harry Potter actors have
been up to since the films ended 1.
Horace Slughorn gym Broadbent Hogwarts
lovable potions professor and head of
Southern house was played by actor Jim
Broadband II before and after Harry
Potter had an illustrious acting career
Broadbent who first joined the cast in
1996 for the Half-Blood Prince has since
starred in a multitude of popular films
TV shows including but certainly not
limited to The Iron Lady a film about
xpm Margaret Thatcher he plays her
husband Dennis Thatcher opposite Meryl
Streep as well as Game of Thrones where
he plays Arch Meister ebros 2. Sirius
blank Gary Oldman when when it comes to
the Harry Potter cast it's hard to
imagine a career more successful or
dynamic than that of Gary Oldman who
plays Harry's Godfather in Marauder
Sirius Black
since Harry Potter ended he's been
involved in a multitude of films
including but not limited to Dawn of the
Planet of the Apes RoboCop Darkest Hour
where he plays Winston Churchill and The
Dark Knight Rises where he plays
Commissioner Gordon 3. Dudley dursley
Harry melling Dudley dursley Harry's
awful cousin who spent his youth making
Harry's life miserable was played by an
actor who incidentally is called Harry
himself Harry melling while melling
seemingly disappeared after the Harry
Potter films had ended I was delighted
to see him in TVs the Queen's Gambit
where he plays yet another Harry Harry
beltick 4. Ginny Weasley Bonnie Wright
Ginny Weasley Weasley family member and
Harry's love interest was played by
actress Bonnie Wright as it turns out
shortly after the Harry Potter films had
ended Wright created her own Film
Production Company Bonbon Lumiere where
she had since been able to stretch her
skill set outside the confines of a
traditional actor while writer starred
in some TV film Works she seems to have
shifted her Focus even more towards
directing and screenwriting in more
recent years
5. Lucius Malfoy Jason Isaacs Lucius
Malfoy who is draco's Dad and one of the
slimiest characters in the series is
played by actor Jason Isaacs since
completing his time as a Harry Potter
cast member Isaacs has been very active
in the acting circuit taking on roles in
other star-studded film franchises TV
series including Star Trek and Star Wars
however that barely scratches the
surface of Isaac's acting resume 6.
Garrick olivender John Hurt Garrick
Ollivander who dulls out ones to the
young witches and wizards in The
Wizarding World was played by iconic
British actor John Hurt tragically hurt
passed away in 2017 but over the course
of his life and career it's very clear
that he certainly wasn't short of
accolades after the last Harry Potter he
landed roles in popular TV series
including Merlin Labyrinth and the last
Panthers among others
7. Ron Weasley Rupert Grint Ron Weasley
of the Weasley Clan and Harry's best
friend is played by actor Rupert Grint
since the Harry Potter films ended Grint
has landed numerous acting roles in
television film my favorite being sick
note where he plays Daniel glass
alongside co-star Nick Frost you may be
also surprised to hear that grind is now
a father having welcomed his first
daughter along in May of 2020 8.
Voldemort wraith fines Lord Voldemort
one of the best villains in film history
was played by none other than Rafe fines
since Harry Potter ended Vines has been
involved in a number of theatrical
Productions as well as some popular
films including the king's man The Grand
Budapest Hotel and recent James Bond
films where he plays the iconic role of
M 9. Remus Lupine David thulis Remus
Lupine Marauder werewolf and one-time
data Professor was played by iconic
British actor David thulis since Harry
Potter ended Fearless has been involved
in various film TV projects including
The Theory of Everything which outlines
a life of theoretical physicist Stephen
Hawking Wonder Woman and 2022's the
Sandman among many others 10. civil
triloni Emma Thompson if we're going to
talk about iconic British actors then we
of course can't forget Emma Thompson who
played Sybil trolloni Hogwarts
questionable divination Professor since
Harry Potter ended Emma has been
involved in a multitude of projects
including but not limited to Men In
Black Saving Mr Banks and Bridget Jones
11. McGonagall Maggie Smith Maggie Smith
who plays Hogwarts Transfiguration
professor and later headmistress manava
McGonagall has fairly openly expressed
her disinterest in discussing the Harry
Potter series days in more recent years
which is why it should come as no
surprise that she has embraced other
projects the most notable probably being
Downton Abbey where she plays Violet
crawly 12. Dumbledore Richard Harris
Michael Gambon Dumbledore Hogwarts
Headmaster and powerful wizard was
originally played by actor Richard
Harris but after he tragically passed
away in 2002 the role was reprized by
actor Michael Gambon since Harry Potter
ended Gambon has been featured in many
shows films including the PBS
mini-series Little Women Victoria and
Abdul kingsman the Golden Circle Dan's
Army and Judy 13. Phyllis Flitwick
Warwick Davis Warwick Davis plays
Professor phyllius Flitwick in the Harry
Potter films also less notably grip Hook
flitwick's character was known for many
things his Mastery of dueling his
teaching of charms and perhaps most
notably being the head of Ravenclaw
House zinn's Harry Potter ended Davis is
featured in a number of films TV shows
including Doctor Who and various
projects inside of the Star Wars
franchise 14. at the fourth Dumbledore
aberforth Dumbledore the brother of
Hogwarts Headmaster Albus Dumbledore was
played by actor Kieran hins since Harry
Potter surrendered hins has featured a
number of films TV shows including Rome
Game of Thrones and Shetland 15. Weasley
twins the mischievous Weasley twins Fred
and George Weasley were planed
respectively by actors James and Oliver
Phelps since Harry Potter ended the
actors have continued to work together
starring in various television acting
roles however it appears that the pair
have also branched out from traditional
media by starting their own podcast
normal not normal 16. Fleur de la core
Clemens Posey Fleur de la core Fierce
trial was a tournament contestant and
later wife to Bill Weasley was played by
actress Clemens Posey since Harry Potter
ended Posey has continued to thrive in
her successful modeling career while
simultaneously Landing roles in big name
films such as tenet 17. James Finnegan
Devin Murray James Finnegan the young
Gryffindor who had a knack for blowing
things amp was played by Irish actor
Devin Murray since Harry Potter ended
Murray appears to have weaned off of
film television and instead seems to be
focusing on his family life in 2018
Murray began dating Shannon Quinn and in
2021 they welcomed their son Cooper 18.
Draco Malfoy Tom Felton Draco Malfoy
Harry's rival and slytherin's poster boy
was played by British actor Tom Felton
since Harry Potter ended Felton has
appeared in a number of indie films and
television programs including From the
Rough and The Apparition however it
would be criminal not to mention
Felton's massive success on social media
platforms particularly Tick Tock at one
point Draco obsessed fans began using
the hashtag Draco talk which became
massively viral
19. Narcissa Malfoy Helen McCrory
Narcissa Malfoy wife of Lucius mother of
Draco and sister of Bellatrix was played
by British actress Helen McCrory
tragically McCrory just passed away last
year in the years after Harry Potter had
ended McCrory found a great deal of
success in various film projects
television programs including Hugo James
Bond Skyfall and peaky blinders R.I.P
Helen
20. Ruby's Hagrid Robbie Coltrane
Hogwarts keeper of keys and grounds and
Harry's protector rubius Hagrid was
played by actor Robbie Coltrane since
Harry Potter ended Coltrane has toned
down the workload and is only featured
in a handful of projects including
Channel 4 Series National Treasure as
well as Pixar's Brave where he voices
Lord dingwald
unfortunately Coltrane was another great
man lost to the passage of time 21.
Cormac mclagan Freddie Stromer Cormac
mclagan the insufferable Gryffindor
student in quidditch player known to
drop his family name with a drop of a
hat was played by actor Freddie Stromer
since Harry Potter ended stroma has
featured in a number of film projects TV
shows including Pitch Perfect Game of
Thrones the in-betweeners and Bridgeton
22. Rita Skeeter Miranda Richardson Rita
Skeeter poison peace expert and
journalist intent on making everyone
look bad was played by actress Miranda
Richardson since Harry Potter ended
Richardson is featured in a number of TV
mini-series including but not limited to
Rubicon Parade's End World Without End
and good Omens
23 Bellatrix Helena Bonham Carter
Bellatrix Lestrange Voldemort's Infamous
right-hand woman was expertly played by
actress Helena Bonham Carter based on
the insanity of her character one might
assume that it would require an actress
who at least Loosely resembled this
character however Carter is certainly
not insane and this is just a testament
to her acting ability zinn's Harry
Potter ended Carters continued to play
other strange and demanding characters
with roles in Dark Shadows Les
Miserables Alice Through the Looking
Glass and Cinderella 24. Cornelius fudge
Robert Hardy Cornelius fudge everyone's
least favorite Minister for magic and
Infamous Voldemort denier was played by
actor Robert hardy hardy tragically
passed away in 2017 at the age of 91 but
it should be noted that Hardy
impressively worked until the day that
he died after Harry Potter had ended
Hardy appeared in TV series little dorit
TV movie Churchill and short Joseph's
reel 25. Dolores Umbridge Imelda
Staunton Dolores Umbridge Tyrant of
Hogwarts students and staff and probably
Harry Potter's best bad guy was expertly
played by actress Imelda Staunton since
Harry Potter ended Staunton has featured
in a number of film television projects
including Maleficent Downton Abbey and
the crown where she plays Queen
Elizabeth II I know you all hate
unbridge but don't direct that anger and
Staunton
26. gilderoy Lockhart Kenneth Branagh
gilderoy Lockhart order of Merlin third
class honorary member of the dark force
Defense League and five-time winner of
which Weekly's most charming smile award
was expertly played by actor Kenneth
Branagh many of you may not know this
but Brana in addition to being an
extremely accomplished actor is also a
very well respected director and writer
after the Harry Potter series came to an
end Branagh featured as an actor in many
popular films including Dunkirk tenet
and murder on the Orient Express which
he also happened to direct
27. Harry Potter Daniel Radcliffe the
man the whole story is based around
Harry Potter was expertly played by
actor Daniel Radcliffe provided that
Daniel's role is synonymous with the
films you'd think that he would have
been Typecast as Harry forever and if
you thought that you'll probably still
right however Radcliffe a truly
dedicated actor clearly has Ambitions of
transcending being just Harry Potter as
he has starred featured in many films
since the Harry Potter films came to an
end since Harry Potter ended Radcliffe
has tried his hand at Broadway starring
in the Broadway musical How To Succeed
In Business Without Really Trying as
well as featured in numerous films
including but not limited to the woman
in black Now You See Me 2 and the lost
city but in what I feel will be his best
performance yet aside from Harry of
course Radcliffe will be starring in the
upcoming Weird Al Yankovic biopic
playing Weird Al himself
28 August filch David Bradley August
filch Hogwarts resident caretaker and
second half to Mrs Norris was played by
actor David Bradley since Harry Potter
ended Bradley has been extremely active
in the film TV industry which is
particularly impressive if we consider
the fact that he's now 80 years old he's
been involved in a multitude of
successful TV series since Harry Potter
ended including afterlife Game of
Thrones Doctor Who and wizards at 80 he
doesn't seem to be slowing down either
May Bradley be an inspiration to us all
29. Arthur Weasley Mark Williams Arthur
Weasley kind patient and caring father
of the impressively large Weasley family
was played by actor Mark Williams since
Harry Potter ended Williams has found a
considerable amount of success in the
long-running BBC TV series Father Brown
where he plays the main character the
the series is currently nine Seasons
strong and looks as though it may be
back for more thirsty Molly Weasley
Julie Walters Molly Weasley mother of
the Weasley Clan and destroyer of
Bellatrix astrange was played by actress
Julie Walters after Harry Potter
rendered Walters among many other things
reprized her role in the Mamma Mia films
played Mrs bird in Paddington and played
Mrs Medlock in The Secret Garden
31. Severus Snape Alan Rickman Severus
Snape one of the most iconic gray
characters in all the film was expertly
played by the late Alan Rickman Rickman
tragically passed away in 2016 but for
five years after the last Harry Potter
film came out continued to Grace us with
his acting in a multitude of projects
these projects included films like a
little chaos Gambit and a promise I
think it's safe to say that Alan Rickman
will be remembered by Harry Potter fans
or always
32 Kingsley shacklebold George Harris
gangster shacklebolds Order of the
Phoenix member and later Minister for
magic was played by actor George Harris
in recent years it appears that Harris
has kept a relatively low profile
seemingly enjoying the fruits of a
success since Harry Potter ended Harris
has only appeared in a few episodes of
TV mini-series including Sinbad and star
hunter Redux
33 Pomona Sprouts Miriam Margulies
Pomona Sprout Hogwarts herbology
professor and head of Hufflepuff house
was played by actress Miriam Margulies
since the end of Harry Potter Margulies
is featured in many popular TV shows
films including Merlin Doc Martin Call
the Midwife and the guilt trip to name a
few
34. Hermione Granger Emma Watson
Hermione Granger Harry's trusty friend
and Ron's later love interest is played
by none other than Emma Watson after the
Harry Potter films had ended Watson went
on to achieve many great things both
inside and outside of the world of
acting in addition to starring in
several films including Beauty and the
Beast The Perks of Being a Wallflower
and Bling Ring Watson was also able to
graduate from Brown University with a
bachelor's degree in English literature
in adulthood Watson has also helped
leverage her platform in order to serve
as an advocate for gender equality 35.
Percy Weasley Chris Rankin Percy Weasley
aka the least popular Weasley child was
played by actor Chris Rankin since Harry
Potter it appears as though Rankin has
slowed down the workload somewhat having
worked on only a few projects these
projects include Total Wipeout the stone
and The Wizard of Oz
36. Oliver wood Sean biger staff
Oliver wood captain and keeper for the
Gryffindor Quidditch team was played by
actor Sean biggerstaff since Harry
Potter ended bigger staff has featured
in numerous short films as well as a few
regular length films and TV programs
these films TV programs include Mary
Queen of Scots Urban myths and super
November
37. petunia dursley Fiona Shaw petunia
dursley Harry's despicable but possibly
very misunderstood and was played by
actress Fiona Shaw since Harry Potter
ended Shaw has featured in a multitude
of TV series including True Blood Mrs
Wilson Baptiste and killing Eve 38.
pansy Parkinson panty Parkinson the
poster girl for Slytherin was most
recently played by actress Scarlett
Byrne since Harry Potter ended Bern is
featured in a number of TV series
including the Vampire Diaries Falling
Skies and runaways burn is married to
Cooper Hefner son of Hugh Hefner 39.
nymphador Tonks Natalia tenor nipador
Tonks wife of Remus and brave Order of
the Phoenix member was played by actress
and musician Natalia tenor since Harry
Potter rendered tenna has featured in
many popular TV programs including Game
of Thrones the Mandalorian and origin
40. Bill Weasley Domino Gleason Bill
Weasley gringott's curse breaker and the
husband of fleur de la core was played
by British actor domnal Gleason the son
of madai Moody actor Brandon Gleason
zinn's Harry Potter ended Gleason has
found an incredible amount of success in
both the TV and film Gleason notably
plays General hux in Star Wars the rise
of Skywalker 41. Dean Thomas Alfred
Enoch Dean Thomas a fellow Gryffindor
and harizir who eventually joins
Dumbledore's Army was played by actor
Alfred Enoch after Harry Potter Enoch
went on to star in ABC's how to get away
with murder
42. Cho Chang Katie Liang Cho Chang a
Ravenclaw student in one of Harry's
First Love interests is played by
actress Katie Liang since Harry Potter
ended the young has kept her workflow
fairly steady featuring in a different
TV program or film every year or so
these films and TV programs include
Trainspotting The Foreigner locked down
and TV series strangers 43. Neville
Longbottom Matthew Lewis actor Matthew
Lewis played the mild natured and later
exceedingly courageous Neville
Longbottom a proud Gryffindor after
Harry Potter ended Lewis made his
onstage debut in 2012 when he featured
in the play our boys Lewis also went on
to Star and feature in a multitude of
films and TV shows in more recent years
Lewis has found a considerable success
in his role as Hugh Holton in TV series
all creatures great and small for 24
Moaning Myrtle Shirley Henderson Moaning
Myrtle a Ravenclaw student killed by
slytherin's basilisk under a young Tom
Riddle's orders was played by actress
Shirley Henderson in the last decade
Anderson is featured in a number of TV
programs including Happy Valley the nest
and South Cliff
45. Luna Lovegood Ivana Lynch actress
Ivana Lynch plays Luna Lovegood The
Eccentric Ravenclaw student who is known
for peculiar Behavior since Harry Potter
Lynch has appeared in a handful of
projects including the BBC drama Silent
Witness Irish independent film my name
is Emily and comedy GBF
46. xenophilius Lovegood Rhys ifans
xenophilius Lovegood the bizarre father
of Luna Lovegood and editor of the
quibbler was played by actor Rhys ifans
since Harry Potter ended ifons has gone
on to appear in numerous films including
the king's man Spider-Man and Snowden
for some reason I always get Reese
confused with Paul Bettany does that
happen to anyone else 47. Katie Bell
Casey Bell Gryffindor student and
Gryffindor quidditch Chaser was played
by actress Georgina Leonidas zinn's
Harry Potter ended Leonidas seems to
have divided her time fairly equally
between theater film and television she
notably appears in the film Papadopoulos
and Sons television program Father Brown
alongside Mark Williams and a theatrical
production of Beauty and the Beast 48.
madai Moody Brendan Gleason madai Moody
Order of the Phoenix member and famous
dark wizard catcher is played by actor
Brendan Gleason father of Bill Weasley
actor Dominic Gleason since Harry Potter
ended Gleason has found considerable
success in television with long-standing
roles in both State of the Union as well
as Mr Mercedes
49. Victor Crumb stanislav yanevsky
Victor Crum Bulgarian and Seeker for the
Bulgarian national Quidditch team was
played by actor stanislav vianevsky
since Harry Potter ended yanevsky has
only appeared in a few television film
projects including resistance last man
down and Undercover
50. patil twins the Patel twins Parvati
and Padma were played by actresses
shefali chudari and afshan Azad since
Harry Potter ended shefali went on to
act in films such as I am the doorway
Heist Jane and odilo Fabia afshan Azad
hasn't appeared in any TV programs or
films since Harry Potter but has
established herself quite well as a
social media personality and that's it
for this video this video was a lot of
fun to make has allowed me to research
so many of my favorite actors I can tell
you that my list of films to watch has
grown a lot were you surprised by any of
this anything important that I missed
then be sure to leave a comment down
below until next time remember there is
plenty to be learned even from a band
teacher what not to do how not to be
foreign